a few days ago I tweeted I will do as
many push ups and pull ups next 30 days
as this tweet gets likes retweets and
comments no number is too high bring it
it got 20,000 so thank you internet
friends for the love and the suffering
it was probably about four or more times
the amount that I was mentally preparing
myself for in the name of health I
decided to spread that around across
multiple body weight exercises including
push-ups and pull-ups but also squats
rollers and running one mile of running
equals 42 push-ups Lex math and I'm
happy with myself I wrote to David
Goggins asking for his advice thoughts
on this challenge
if you don't know David Goggins he to me
is one of the toughest most inspiring
humans in the planet retired Navy SEAL
ultra marathon runner
former record holder for the most
pull-ups and 24 hours author of the book
can't hurt me that highly recommend
especially the audiobook anyway I asked
him a few questions about this challenge
and he was kind enough to respond i'll
linter leave the clips into the video so
the first thing I did is I explained to
him the challenge and the way I spread
it around across multiple bodyweight
exercises and just asked him for his
thoughts about what I'm doing well it's
a pretty good damn workout this the
issue right there man I believe the ITO
people aren't I think it was Twitter I'm
not quite for sure I think was Twitter
that you would do push-ups and pull-ups
for the number of week retweets that you
had now I'm hearing running I'm hearing
squats I'm hearing I am here push-ups
and pull-ups I'm hearing all kind of
different other exercises and you also
told people that guess what bring it no
numbers to I but now are your other
exercises that must mean that there is a
number too high so be careful what you
wish for my friend
so that being said I would have stuck
with the damn push-ups and pull-ups and
challenged yourself to the up teeth
degree of pain and suffering and that
would have really taught you a humongous
lesson about yourself and and everything
else but what you have here is also
amazing but it's nothing compared to uh
what she had you know previously talked
about well there you have it
when David Goggins calls you out in your
[ __ ] you got to step up so I'm gonna
do what I originally promised which is
the 20,000 push-ups and pull-ups and on
top of that I'll do my best to do also
the other bodyweight exercises really
for the sake of health so we're talking
about squats ab rollers and running the
whole goal I wanted to do here is
something that's healthy but still
pushes me to my limits physically
mentally and allows me to build up a
habit of doing some efficient exercise
every day you know something that takes
less than an hour but keeps me in pretty
sharp hard shape that's why I do here
certainly with 20,000 push-ups and
pull-ups that's a whole nother level I
don't know what's gonna happen but I
will learn something about myself for
sure so I want to mention some of the
reasons some of the motivations of why
I'm doing this challenge so first is I
didn't think too much about I just dive
right in it was actually just laying in
bed and tweeted it out I think some of
the craziest most fun some of the most
ambitious things we can take on in life
sometimes can be just on a whim so I'm
decided on the whim we're gonna take it
to completion I also wanted to do an
exercise program that I've done often in
the past that takes very little effort
so like being busy is not an excuse it
can take 20-30 minutes a day just to get
a hard workout in you can do it at home
there's no excuse not to do it the other
thing is that travel is not an excuse
because it's body weight you could
basically do it anywhere you probably
heard me talk a lot about it before but
I'm a huge believer in habits coz habits
remove the need for day to day
motivations that can go up and down I
have a lot of research work related to
have us that a part of my life but I
wanted to get exercise
as part of a daily routine in my life I
think especially in these times of the
coronavirus and all the madness that's
going on in the world being healthy
making sure you're strengthening your
immune system with good diet good sleep
good exercise it's really important for
everybody everybody's kind of locked up
and it's easy to slack on the exercise
and I I wanted to motivate others
perhaps to join me on getting their
exercise back on getting back out there
getting a little bit of movement every
single day and also I wanted to harden
up that muscle of doing the thing you
don't want to do for that long period of
time and getting it done so I actually
asked David what should I do when things
get tough haha it's a good [ __ ]
question make it is going to get [ __ ]
difficult day after day after day that's
the thing about what you're doing right
now that's that's challenging is a lot
of the [ __ ] can sign up for the
[ __ ] one-day event why don't we do a
lot of these CEOs a lot of these people
don't want to suffer you know as a
living who don't want to suffer as
making it a habit what they do is they
go out and they recruit these people to
put them through a 2 day 3 day [ __ ]
challenge anybody can do that [ __ ]
because your mind can process two or
three [ __ ] days of Sun what you're
doing my friend is going to be damn near
a month of suck so basically you're
gonna have a lot of days especially in
the morning time the mornings when you
wake up and your body says go [ __ ]
yourself because I don't [ __ ] feel
like doing this today and you're gonna
look at cuz you're running 6 miles a day
I believe you know what's going to
happen to your [ __ ] ass you're gonna
wake up in the morning and you're gonna
[ __ ] do what I do people think I love
David Geiger's just wakes the [ __ ] up
and he just gets just [ __ ] on he gets
this book after I know I don't get up
and get after it I look at my shoes
sometimes for hours I passed them I go I
get stuff to drink I go to the bathroom
I watch TV I started doing some work and
I look at those [ __ ] shoes because
why my body saying go [ __ ] yourself
so you have to be able to win the
morning
you have to be able to not allow that to
get too deep in your brain and when
things get really tough for you when
you're out there on like day 17 and your
knees are hurting and your back is hurt
and your shoulders are hurting you l
will get elbow tendonitis and all kind
of [ __ ] going on you got to start
remembering your resume a lot of people
don't remember what the [ __ ] they've
accomplished in life and at that time of
suffering you have to be able to [ __ ]
go through and pull up that [ __ ] who
the [ __ ] I am resume and say oh for you
you I'm sure you studied your [ __ ]
ass off for hours and days and years to
get where you're at I guarantee you did
[ __ ] harder than this and that's
basically what you have to go back to
but it's hard to do because in that
moment of suffering all you can [ __ ]
think about is getting the [ __ ] out of
it so you got take that one second to
pull yourself out of that suffering to
have a clear [ __ ] thought it's hard
to have clear thoughts in the midst of
extreme pain and suffering find that
clear thought remind yourself of what
you've been through back in the past
back in the day to get to where you're
at today so that's what I do is a
constant reminder and then through that
process I guarantee you your mind and
body muster up we got this we've we've
been here before maybe not that kind of
pain and suffering but we've been here
before in the demons of your own mind so
that's the best reminder in the world
all right so what I'm going to attempt
I'm going to do as 20,000 push-ups and
pull-ups combined and on top of that I'm
also going to do squats ab rollers and
run six miles everyday so the routine is
this run six miles and then do 34 rounds
of the following
15 push-ups 5 pull-ups 5 ab rollers and
10 squats just over and over 34 times a
day I might split it up 3 times a day I
might do it twice a day I might do it
just one a day my plan is to do the
hardest one early on in the day try to
get as much done as possible most likely
about 14 rounds and then do another 10
and 10 later on in the day the goal is
for each round like that to take about
two minutes so for 34 rounds that's 68
minutes so the start is tomorrow
Wednesday June 10th going on for 30 days
after that so let me quickly do around
to give you a sense of the form and then
talk about it
you
so there you have it that's one round
the hope for that is to take about a
minute and the total is two minutes to
get a break of about a minute between
each each session obviously good form is
important there's always going to be a
keyboard warrior out there I'm looking
at you with some sweat bands in their
mom's basement with Cheetos all over the
place we had a shape
who's gonna comment about the fact that
the push-ups aren't all the way down or
aren't all the way up and the same with
the pull ups so on and so forth
none of that matters good form in this
case for a push up and a pull up it's
something that minimizes the risk of
injury I think this whole thing is a
tough workout to be honest yesterday and
the day before I did over 400 which was
I was trying to see is this even
possible
can I do 680 total push up some pull-ups
in a day it seems like an insane number
to me so so I did 400 and it was tough
but doable and I think if 400 is doable
than 680 is - I think I can certainly
with a little bit of suffering do it for
a few days if I can be fortunate enough
to avoid injury the rest of the month is
just mental that's where the battle is
that's where all the good lessons like
to be learned
so I also asked David by the way there's
a laptop over here
that's what I'm working over here I also
asked David about you know about the
fact that some people might join in on
this challenge in whatever capacity they
can and what he recommends for me and
for others to stay injury-free while
still pushing their body and their mind
to the limit
well this challenge you're going to get
injured if you don't have a good base
like for instance if you don't do a lot
of pull-ups a lot of push-ups what you
do for both is you're utilizing these
elbows which you get tendonitis severely
bad and your shoulders so with the
push-up you're here this is your hinge
part yet you are using your chest using
your triceps but this hinge is being
used an awful lot this elbow hinge these
shoulders are being used offline even
pull up motion being used offline so
basically what happens is you're going
to get injured so for a lot of you I
would definitely suggest doing a lot
more squats do a lot more apps doing
things like that even abs you can eat
your ass but going from zero to hero you
will have some injuries and you got this
Isum try to get your body to recover as
fast as possible taking the proteins
taking the minnows things like that
getting as much rest as you can but
you're going to get over overuse start
training issues with you know with your
body that just comes with it it's just
nature of the beast and like I said
those do start to get injured start
doing those uh start making those squats
you know you're your go-to because your
legs can handle so much when I was doing
the pull-up record people wondered why
that was so hard for me first of all I
had a jacked up body when I was doing it
a very uh I guess out of alignment body
but your only contact point is your
hands and there's been times in too much
of my races where I tore my quad
completely tore my quad I was able to
bandage it up and walk it out I was able
to walk seventy-five miles so this two
thing your legs can handle a lot of
abuse a lot of abuse so we start hurting
go to your legs so there you have it
don't use any kind of injuries an excuse
to stop to stop moving stop exercising
just find an alternative exercise that
doesn't hurt you know I'm gonna really
try to stick to the push up and pull up
and do everything I can to remain injury
free for me a part of voiding injury is
stretching really well also doing a good
warm-up like for me I'm doing the six
mile run before doing the body weight
exercises also obviously nutrition is
important
everybody has their own journey I've
dieted my whole life all kinds of ways
then combat sports my whole life so
cutting weight and performing optimally
was always important for me whatever you
think about it the main diet that I've
come to enjoy is either keto or
carnivores so primarily a meat-based
diet meat and fat very low carb so
mostly for me that just means ground
beef sometimes steak and keto friendly
little carb snacks and their nutrition
wise it's pretty basic but I did do take
some stuff so I take sodium in my food
so I put quite a bit of salt in there
magnesium also take fish oil and pill
form not much like two or three fish oil
pills a day and in a multivitamin that's
it it would be of course awesome if
other folks if you decided to join in on
this challenge in whatever level you
want it just be fun to do push ups and
pulls together or any kind of difficult
exercise activity that will challenge
you do it every single day if you
haven't ramped up to it you haven't done
it much what I recommend is to start
very low - we're almost you're
comfortable and then increase your
day-by-day - when you quickly become
uncomfortable but give your body time to
adjust that's like really important
again the point here is to do a
difficult exercise but really is to do
it for thirty days and what I'm doing
and I hope you do as well it's not just
for 30 days it's for 30 days you do
something difficult but you form that
habit and you stick to it for months to
come especially in these times exercise
is just so important for staying healthy
and staying sane so I'd love it if you
joined in on the challenge of a
spreadsheet linked in the description
well I'll keep track of the reps that
I'm doing on a daily basis just so you
can follow along you can also just copy
that spreadsheet and use it for yourself
to track your own numbers share with me
on any of the social platforms I'd love
to see your progress
I'll also maybe go live on one of the
Platt
forms Instagram YouTube on our discord
server Twitter I don't know I don't know
if there's interesting that I'll be
honest I tried Instagram live a couple
of days ago to work out and it was a
little weird for me to work out other
people watched I'm not sure but maybe if
there's interests let me know maybe I
can take a few questions about the
challenge I'll probably record video
throughout the month and just publish it
at the end so with that I'd like to
thank David Goggins I follow him on
Instagram and he's a constant reminder
that I need to push myself to my limit
mentally I asked them of course whether
he want to be a guest in the podcast
let's see what he had to say no problem
man I love what you do I've seen some of
your work you're extremely intelligent
guy so your intelligence and I see that
you're willing to go the next mile so
you you're willing to be a guy that is
just not alright so for instance I was
in the military they say you better be
real smart or you better [ __ ] be real
hard and so I was the real hard guy and
I had to develop the smarts
I see that you're a really smart guy and
you're developing the heart so I think
that uh we can really have a good
podcast together be it'd be pretty you
know interesting conversation so there
you have it
it's on I think I'm recording this video
but most of this journey is quiet it's
on my onus with myself
it's a quiet journey of suffering so yes
it's the way to get exercise back in my
life but it's really a chance to
rediscover myself by doing something
really really difficult for a prolonged
period of time no matter what I'll be a
different and I think a better human
being on the other end if you join me on
this in your own parallel journey great
either way stay healthy and stay hard
you